true I was giving her massages and
little juju is sitting there and we're
watching planet Earth our planet on
Netflix
whatever episode three jungles jungles
and which they know a lot about so do
you Gilbert love it you guys thrive know
90% of the jungles in the Philippines
have been destroyed and you got Isla and
then also a lot of Borneo now because of
all the palm oil and the palm tree my
question is if you don't do that where
we gonna put the Starbucks that's my
question so uh sometimes the rainforest
has to go for our Starbucks but um it's
terrible it may be at Jersey Mike's you
know what if the rainforests are gone
they're not gonna you're no longer gonna
see your favorite bird of paradise the
one that does like CGI effects those
[ __ ] birds of paradise and in the
Indian Papua New Guinea New Guinea and
all that stuff they date you know the
males they have to do extra [ __ ] it's
kind of like humans except you don't do
extra [ __ ] they do what these birds are
doing it to attract the mate but once
they're together the a black pieces of
[ __ ] I already did the bird of prey
thing earlier the bird of prey but the
bird of paradise answer to get you but
once I got you hooked in then he stops
doing all the fancy [ __ ] with this
[ __ ] wings you know I mean so like so
we're watching it yeah
and we're massaging and an animal came
onto the screen okay yeah I remember
an animal came on the screen and this
animal was on a tree looking out into
the you know the jungle and we all
collectively said that's Gila burn
honestly I'm right we all at the same
bird it wasn't unfortunately it was an
old male orangutan the one with the
facial flat the flaps as he turned this
way and
Zaber yeah it looked exactly like you
Gilbert so I think that you know through
evolution you you're from the orangutan
I'm at it closest to can you can you
look it up look it up just put dominant
male orangutan and it's uh Borneo Borneo
it's definitely our planet because he
had a name what was his name wasn't
Louie no you yeah no Louie was a tiny
one was the no he was like the second
oldest kid yeah he's a little baby he's
like a teenager rebellious yeah the
rebellious one did you find it killed
yeah I'm kind of looking for Louie yeah
no not Louie my god shut the Horta
listener or listener listener tang man
there's so many beautiful ones if so
much that mentioned interphase orangutan
male biggest face yeah bear I already
found it what is it the easiest thing to
find guild say some of us have slow
internet these days yeah just put it on
the screen okay yeah yes that's you but
okay first of all I don't have side
cheeks like that that she I should do
but if the Revolution it dwindled down a
little bit but if you look at it the
face if you just look at the phase you
can see complete in fact if I was a
honestly if I was like a caricature you
know on the boardwalk or you go to you
know I mean they have those guys that
draw and I would probably draw that and
you would've looked at it anyone okay
that was dead-on I will show you my
character from Six Flags next week the
guy that it's so [ __ ] big yeah Oh
guild but you know what's cool about
being an ape is that you have what
humans no longer have because we we have
monogamy in our culture what it is you
still have a tiny bit of a dick bone a
baculum a what what so a dick bone is
something that a lot of bone is baby
and I hope you don't have a bone I hope
you've evolved there's no ball bone in
there you don't have a baculum babe so
there's no bone in the dick you're gonna
have a ball dick bone babe